what's up y'all it's your man tyreese i
play roman pierce and the fast and the
furious
what's going on i'm chris ludacris
bridges i play teja in the fast
franchise but i'm here to take the
buzzfeed quiz
to see which character in the fast
franchise i most like
[Music]
which car would i use in a street race a
yellow coupe silver sports car
black bimmer red viper blue muscle car
or black spy convertible the red viper
is my choice man i'd probably use the
red viper
just because i love the color red your
insurance goes sky high when you have a
red car
and because the viper is just a it's a
badass car man i mean come on
what is your role in your friend group
the leader the comic relief
the parental figure the chef the planner
sidekick
are we talking about roman pierce are we
talking about tyrese
i'm the planner i'm gonna have to save
the leader you won one million
what would you spend it on clothes my
friends my family jewelry
houses cars none of the above i'm gonna
have to go with houses
serial entrepreneur investments i would
be making the real estate market is
always a great investment
with these investments i would take care
of my family
but i would not give my family a million
dollars because it should disappear in
two seconds
your friend calls you in the middle of
the night asking for help what do you do
drop everything and run to their side
before the phone hangs up
miss the call tell them you'll call them
back when you're up try to handle the
problem over the phone
see if the problem can be dealt with
later immediately facetime them instead
probably immediately facetime them
because i have a way of calming people
down in the middle of a crisis
well i'm gonna have to say drop
everything and run to their side before
the phone hangs up that's just what type
of friend i am what do you consider to
be your best feature
my eyes my hair my muscles my style my
personality my wit
i'm gonna have to go with all of the
above
can i do that i would save my
personality that includes wit
i would want to choose my muscles but
gonna have to go with my personality
which city would you most like to
holiday in new york city los angeles
chicago miami washington dc
or houston miami is my favorite place to
go
i want to be in miami the party central
which word
would your bff use to describe you
selfless
loyal brave intelligent strong
passionate
i mean i have a few of them selfless
loyal brave
intelligence strong and passionate
selfless i would say
selfless what do you consider to be the
most important thing in your life
my family my friends my education my
money
my property my pet i'm gonna save my
family my family which fnf movie
is your favorite fast and furious the
fate of the furious fast and furious six
furious seven
two fast two furious or fast five i'm a
little biased about too fast too furious
because it was my debut and me and paul
walker had the best time ever making it
i'm going with fast five baby and
finally what can we find you drinking on
a saturday night
water juice smoothie soda wine
or corona it's the first four i don't
drink wine i don't drink alcohol
never had an alcohol drink in my life
i'm gonna have to go with the red wine
love wine it's good for your heart
i am most like dominic terreto in the
franchise
it says i'm dominic tiretto a
natural-born leader who would do
anything for people closest to him
you're a bit of a risk-taker
but hey danger just makes life more fun
i'll take that i agree i'm definitely a
natural-born leader
shout out to dominic toretto a.k.a thank
you buzzfeed
i hope y'all take the quiz too let's see
what your results are
[Music]
you